foreign
I need help like
how do I deal with a husband that just
doesn't lead what does that mean well he
doesn't bond with our son usually when
somebody we're gonna make some people
mess
[Music]
hey yo what's up this is John the Dr
John deloney show
[Music]
Dr mental health parenting education
whatever's going on in your life what's
going on with your kids what's going
with you what's going on with college
with middle school elementary school
whatever is going on in your world
here to walk alongside you here's what
the show's about helping you have a
better marriage here's what this show is
about helping you to take control of
your mental health help you figure out
what's going on in your kids schools
what's going on in the world around us
what's going on in your business
whatever's going on in your life
my goal is to sit here and walk
alongside you I just said sit here and
walk alongside you I gotta pick one of
those things I'm not just gonna sit here
I am going to walk with you and uh we're
gonna figure out the next right move
um
to the just countless folks who have
written in their stories for success
thank you so much the it's um when I do
this show there's no audience here I
mean and I always am talking about the
audience and I'm like it's packed out
there usually that means there's one or
two people that just showed up early
um
I do this show and then I go to some
meetings and then I go lock myself in a
dark room and write for a while then I
just go home and so your feedback is
such a gift it's just a gift um those of
you who write notes you let me know hey
I started trying this thing and my
marriage is better I've connected with
my seven-year-old again I'm a better
parent I'm a better dad all those those
stories
um are just like cool water in a desert
so thank you so much for sending those
in
um don't forget to hit the Subscribe
button it means all it makes all the
difference in the world uh hit the
Subscribe button um five star reviews
all that kind of thumbs up whatever you
I don't know what what buttons you're
pushing these days on the interwebs but
push the good ones for us and um we'll
be super super grateful for you let's go
out to Elizabeth in the NYC what's up
Elizabeth how we doing
the John
we are rocking on how how's things in
New York
oh boy it's crazy I mean it's cold one
day I mean we got Spring today we'll
probably have winter tomorrow fall the
next day it's crazy out here but hey
gotta love it this is New York right
we're crazy out here hey you you said it
not me I'll just let you I'll let you
have that one oh yeah that one so what's
up
oh what is enough Dr John
um oh geez I need help like
I just don't know where to start I mean
I'm a mess my life's a mess my marriage
is a mess but I'm struggling struggling
for a long time now with my marriage I
mean how do I deal with a husband that
just doesn't lead
usually when somebody I'm gonna make
some people mad when somebody usually
when somebody tells me
their husband's not leading oh boy
um that means that their husbands are
terrible mind readers or they're super
lazy they won't get a job they're just
they're just they're just bums so oh boy
tell me what what is what does the
phrase he's not a leader what does that
mean to you
um yeah I guess well I guess underneath
that is that he just doesn't give his
100 percent
I mean it's it's what does that mean e
he well he doesn't like
bond with our son I am overwhelmed with
responsibilities that you know I need
help with
and I've asked for this help from him
for years and like nothing changes
um two things
um number one he's not giving a hundred
percent
is very different than he's not bonding
with his son
I mean but I I count that as not giving
your hundred percent no I'm telling you
he's failing his son
exactly is that's that's not giving a
hundred percent you get I tell I tell my
son I I get it yeah so here's what's
important for me
um
I can already tell you have to be very
careful with your language in your home
don't you
I do okay can't do that here we have to
be super honest with each other is that
fair
your husband is failing your son
right now number two you said you've
been telling him for years this is you
this is you and me two new best friends
have you been very clear or have you
said things like I could just use some
help around here I sure am tired hoping
he would understand that means hey I
need help with bedtime you need to
re-roof the house and then we need help
with dishes or have you said will you
please help with the dishes
oh my goodness
um it's been Dr John it's been 14 years
16 years together and I I couldn't even
begin to imagine how many times we've
had this conversation
um it's uh straightforward you know uh
I've even had to switch uh you know uh
when we have these conversations like I
know it can't be you know after an
argument or when things are tense I've
tried to talk about it when we're calm
and things are good I've tried to uh
you're gonna hate my answer
I've tried everything
that's not true
you don't think so I know so
how
you're still there
oh my god well it's true but but we have
been separated twice almost got divorced
like three years ago and I mean I I
really
I it's like I want to to I want to work
this I want to keep my family together
but he doesn't he doesn't Elizabeth
ah he doesn't want that he wants a maid
and he wants someone he wants someone to
take care of his kids so he doesn't have
to and he wants someone to sleep with
every every once in a while
yeah that that yeah that that's
ridiculous it's been months and months
and months like how can I and my my main
thing Elizabeth doesn't want it
he doesn't I mean behavior is a language
what's he telling you I don't care what
you need I don't care what's gonna make
you whole I don't care what's gonna make
you well I care about me
right
why are you but you're but you're
fighting it you're like going to the
ocean you're getting mad at the waves it
just is the only thing you can control
here you can't so your question to me
was how do I deal with a husband who
won't lead you can't you can only deal
with you
yeah
well you're you're staring at a purple
unicorn and you so badly want it to be
red and it's not
it's not
oh man but it's like ah but like it's
and then it's too it's like it's been 14
years like what am I gonna do like like
be out there a divorced mom like
struggling with two kids like I I just
what message do you want your kids to
get
oh geez if this is what love looks like
or this is what self-respect looks like
you know what it's it's really it's
crazy because my best friend you know
kind of said something like that to me
and I thought about our daughter as
since the age of 10 this child has been
saying yo I'm never getting married I am
never having kids I don't want any of
that and I think back and I'm like how
at 10 years old
does she figure this out already like
she absorbs she thinks it's the air she
breatheses
bye
is the air she sees your disdain
she sees all the stuff that I have on my
plate that's not it that's not it she
feels your resentment
she feels how much you disdain that man
when he walks in the room because you
can't stand it yeah but worse than that
you can't stand you Elizabeth
because in every facet of your life in
every facet of your life you are a
straight gangster
you're a great yeah Mom you're a great
provider you no matter what it is you
get it done
yeah except for for some reason
you don't think you're worthy of being
loved
so you just keep taking it you just keep
taking it or or your fantasy about what
you want this thing to look like is is
has more weight
than somebody sitting down at the
kitchen table before you go to work and
saying two things
every day I thank God that I get to be
your husband and how can I love you
better today
oh my God I'm I'm sorry because it's
it's so true like I swear why why do you
think so little of my friend Elizabeth
because I like her it seems like since
the day I was born I've just been in
survival mode Dr John like I've had to
fend for myself in so many different
areas of my life you know I my parents
split up you know and from the age of
seven I didn't have my father in my life
and I've just been out here just trying
to make it in life you understand and
listen listen to me listen to me kills
me because you think okay you're married
you have someone to do life with but I
find myself still surviving every damn
day and I'm just like how how do I deal
with this without without breaking up my
family that's the only thing that I
think about but you're not breaking up
your family you're right your husband
did it he has
your husband uh
I'm trying to
your parents were divorced y'all are
essentially divorced too
you don't sleep together you don't do
life together you don't share you don't
share expenses y'all don't do anything
together
no except you have this fantasy that I'm
keeping the family together
you're not there you're y'all are
divorced you just live in the same
apartment in New York
that's that's true it's true that's how
I feel I feel like it is Mom most times
anyways it is
you just haven't you haven't you have
more laundry to do
yeah
now I never I want you to hear me very
carefully I'm using a technique on you
okay
okay here's the technique I'm using I am
hitting the pendulum really hard in One
Direction
and the reason I'm doing that is I want
you to push back hard and say no no no
this man loves me and I love him I am
not in the business of telling people to
get married unless very rare situations
I mean I mean I'm sorry I'm always
telling people to get married I think
marriage is awesome I'm not in the
business of breaking up marriages
telling somebody they should get
divorced right um except in very rare
moments so I'm leaning on you
and every time I ask a harder and harder
question you're like oh God you're right
oh God you're right that's true
I want to honor your your
sweet beautiful
nine-year-old kid that's still wondering
why Dad laughed
why what was so wrong with me I was a
beautiful little girl why'd you leave
exactly what I I did for so long you
know and yeah your body you still are
but he laughed your husband left I want
my son to think that there's something
wrong with him because his father
doesn't want to spend time with him get
to know him do things with him I I don't
want my my daughter to think that there
was something wrong with her like like
but you but you can't make that choice
your husband has to be a father and he's
choosing not to so he has taken that
cinder block and dropped it into their
tiny little backpacks and said hey y'all
carry this
I want to do something else
yeah yes how
how building up and it's building up and
I can't help but change the way I see
him like this is not the man who I
thought I married but it's it but it is
the man you married
Dr John so listen choose guilt over
resentment
choose guilt over resentment
what uh what I mean
that means I can do one of two things
when my well and I'm just gonna make up
a story because she doesn't do this if
my my mom says Hey for Thanksgiving
y'all are driving all the way to Texas
and I'd say hey we can't we can't afford
that drive it's too far for that short
of a time and she said and she she says
something like you will be at my house
we do Thanksgiving at my house you will
be here I don't care where you live
don't disrespect your mom that way
if she were to do this and again my mom
would never do that if she did I would
have a choice
I could pile my family up in the car put
the trip on a credit card and be raged
out angry the entire trip
when my daughter says Daddy I gotta go
to the bathroom I'm sick come on come on
just hold it we gotta I can be that Dad
all the way there and all during
Thanksgiving I could be annoyed that I
was there checking my phone waiting to
see what what what work stuff I'm
missing
um then all of a sudden you know my mom
says hey go pick up some pizzas so I
gotta put more money on the credit card
right
I'm just gonna end in Rage in resentment
in Ash
or I can say Mom I can't make it this
year we are not coming I love you if you
choose to take this as a sign of
disrespect you're you're free to I think
the best way I can show you respect is
to honor my wife and my kids and my
family because you taught me to do that
and I'm going to do that in this season
and I'm gonna hang up the phone I'm
gonna feel so guilty
for bailing on my mom but I'm not gonna
drag me and my family through
the hell that is resentment
that feeling of just disdain when
somebody walks in right or if he looks
at you and says hey we get the kids to
bed early tonight and you just want to
throw up like gross like I'm you know
you know what I mean yeah or he comes
home drinking again or he comes home not
at all and then he shows up the next day
and wants to know where breakfast like
just just all of it all of it your kids
are absorbing every second of that and
that seven-year-old little girl still
wondering why he leave me too
he's sitting on my couch but he left me
too why
why so true
and so here's here's the hard place
where you find yourself
it's a place where I don't like to be I
don't know anybody who likes to be here
foreign
you have to choose reality
not the fantasy that you want to keep up
not the protection of that
seven-year-old little girl
she's been fighting her fights for a
long long time Elizabeth
if choose reality
for 14 years I've told my husband I need
some help
I need you to love me
enough to help out with these kids I
need you to take your son and connect
with this young boy who's looking to you
as the picture of what man who looks
like a father who looks like what love
looks like what compassion looks like
what responsibility looks like I need
you to connect with your daughter my dad
didn't do that to me and I'm still
haunted by it I need you to make sure
that girl knows that come hell or high
water
she's the most beautiful thing that ever
walked the Earth and there will be a man
that loves her
every moment for the rest of her life
and that's her dad
and if he chooses not to do that you've
got to live in that reality and then
you've got to ask yourself that
terrifying question what am I going to
do next and I'm not saying you got to
get divorced am I saying that at all
but you've been separated separate
several times you almost got divorced
like you've been down this road before
but something keeps bringing you back
and it sounds like it's the fantasy it's
the picture of I also know that the data
is really clear when
um a woman chooses to leave
especially women with kids her net worth
goes down the chances of ending up in in
poverty are significant it's hard and
more frustrating his net worth often
goes up
super frustrating I get all that so I
know there's a lot of complications here
you've got to get some friends in your
corner that you can sit down and lay all
your stuff out and say here is reality
what am I gonna do next
what am I going to do next
you've been fighting for a long long
long time let's set the gloves down and
let's exhale
and let's get some water and let's meet
with our coaches and figure out what
what's the game plan because what we've
been doing isn't working
[Music]
it sounds a lot like you got one option
left I don't want to put that on you but
it sounds like you've done everything
you could you could put your head on
your pillow at night no one I gave it my
all I gave it my own
be right back
I've got a word from our sponsor better
help listen I've been on both ends of
therapy in my life I've gotten it myself
and I've walked people through it and
I've seen the benefits from both sides
when someone owns their past and the
cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right let's go out to Lucy in
Jacksonville
Lucy in the Sky What's up Lucy
hey Dr John how are you partying what
are you up to
I am sitting in my office wondering if
you can help me with something I'm not
partying and hey we can help each other
let's do this all right so what's up
sounds good so I have the awesome
privilege of running a Crisis Pregnancy
Center
um in a rural town oh good for you hey
can we just can I celebrate you thank
you yeah thank you it takes a lot of us
but you don't make enough money for what
you're doing you it says Crisis
Pregnancy on your business card but you
do way way more than that
and you do that way way for more people
than just those
scared terrified soon to be moms who
show up in at your front door thank you
thank you thank you thank you it's an
awesome privilege you're such a gift man
you're on the express I just I'm
grateful for you thank you all right so
how can I help thank you
okay so uh obviously uh in your case as
well over over the time that we have
with individuals we're not going to be
able to make a difference in each of
their lives because they each have a
choice
um but I do want to focus on making a
choice for some that are looking at
depending on the government
for a lifetime of assistance instead of
just for a season again very rural area
a lot of Section 8 housing like the
majority of the town is Section 8
housing government assistance free
school lunches and it's generationally
just accepted that that's how they have
to live
and we have Financial classes in place
beyond just our parenting and pregnancy
classes that we want to incorporate some
sort of different tactic or some sort of
additional tactic that I could speak
into their lives that hey you are worth
so much more than just living
this one check from the government every
month and Beyond you are worth going to
school if that is something that you
want to uh
seek out how can I get them to listen to
me when generationally it's been
accepted it's even encouraged Dr John in
our area to have children to continue to
continue this cycle and again I'm not
going to reach everybody and that's okay
but for the one that will listen what's
a tactic that I can incorporate that I
may not be thinking of now
um man that's such a great great
question
um and you know this I'm so I'm saying
this for the audience you're talking
about asking somebody
who's watched their grandparents and
their parents and their friends
grandparents and their friends parents
jump in a stream that's just going to
carry them on and what we're asking them
to do what you're asking to do is I want
you to walk into the ocean and swim
against that tide and I want you to swim
all the way out because you have no idea
what's out there farther than you can
see
absolutely so what we're asking them to
do is something virtually impossible and
here's why they have no picture of what
this looks like it's all unicorns and
rainbows and cotton candy because
they've never seen it they've never
experienced they don't know what it is
so it's like it's like
I just think about like uh listen like
when I was a high school teacher and
you'd listen to kids talking about like
making out with with you know somebody
who had never made out them trying to
explain it to each other was in was
always hilarious
because it's like you are in you have no
idea right and so
um and probably of all the the analogies
I could have given you that was the
worst I like I just High School boys
talking about making out but here's
here's the thing
they have to have a new picture of what
this looks like and this new picture is
going to be at odds with everything they
know and so
I'm thinking of a couple of things I've
used over the years almost always it is
involving people who have left
made the changes in inviting them and
sometimes paying them to come back
because somebody who's left and has gone
on to Community College and then gone to
get a four-year degree at a local school
or whatever the thing is there they they
went got their welding certificate and
they're making some money
they walk back in the door and everybody
goes oh that person looks just like me
that person's me you Lucy you're not
you're the boss you're Miss right you're
you're the you're the man you're the the
in parentheses whoa you're the you're
the man right
but she looks just like us or he looks
just like us
um
this is years ago that I read this
literature so it may have shifted but it
used to be that somebody walks into a
room that's full of people and they scan
that room
for right to left or left to right and
they give that room seven seconds to for
their body to decide I belong here or I
do not belong here
somebody stands up in front of them and
says I'm one of you you get seven
seconds and and again that's not that's
not precise but somebody who's been
there and comes back is crucial somebody
who's had success at a local school or
is in school now that comes back and
says let me tell you about how different
your life can be
somebody who crawled their way out there
you go and most people who crawled their
way out had a coach or somebody that
carried them a little bit of the way or
that one English teacher or that one
geometry teacher whoever who said hey
hold on uh my mom is a perfect example
of it
um just didn't have any pictures of
educated women in her family lineage and
then one teacher at one Community
College Class said
hey I don't know if you know this but
you're the smartest kid in this class
she's like I'm not a kid I'm 43 years
old and she says I know and I don't want
you to stop and uh you've probably heard
you've probably heard me talk about my
mom here but zero schooling until 42.
none and graduated with her PhD at 57
and she's in her 70s and she's going to
do her last summer at Oxford this summer
like she's just a complete back uh
second half of her life but because a
couple of professors said holy smokes
you got something really special right
and they just she said I can be one of
you guys I can be one of y'all right and
so that's that's number one
um the second one is
often I find people
um so I I have a thing whenever I go do
public I go do speeches I go do talks I
always have really
um misleading titles of my talks and
here's why people look at that title
they prejudge it they call it they
already think they know how this thing
ends and they check out before you even
start
so I want you to look at the names of
your classes if you have a parenting
class A how to be married class and then
a money class
it's very easy to look at that and go I
don't need that I got that the like my
check just comes
if you had a life 101 course or a how to
be happy course or how to have less
um abuse in your life course
and in these like and I'm trying to
think of just titles that might appeal
to folks in
um that you are working with
um folks who have been on the other side
of opiate recovery and they're and they
can come back and say hey here's what
this looks like on the other side of
this right because I know you deal with
that too I'm certain so right being able
to say
um here's a class that you might be
interested in in that class we're going
to weave the financial principles into
that class
um I like that this is an aside I'm
going to send you five Financial Peace
University courses that you can give
away okay thank you for a year and so if
somebody comes in and you it's all the
videos they can log in check out all the
videos you could probably even show the
videos in a class I don't know how all
that works you can talk to Jenna um and
figure out how that works but
um yeah we've already got one client in
there and she's loving it with her
husband so okay all right great
um the one cool thing is is most people
think Financial Peace is just about
getting out of debt that's a part of it
but it's the the the master Mastery of
that course is empowerment you can do
anything
right and there's something about here's
a tiny direct path it's very simple and
it's very straightforward so even when
you get into the dark and you're in the
middle of the ocean and you've been
swimming and you can't see Shore and you
can't see where you're headed
you know that okay I just gotta keep
going I just gotta keep going I gotta
keep going
so those are a couple of my ideas there
um
what's something you've tried that
doesn't work at all
we encourage
um
continuing education a lot of our
clients come without even a high school
diploma so if they if they promise to go
to their help classes to study for the
GED test we pay for that test so that is
one thing that we would love to see more
clients take advantage of just doesn't
happen I don't know if that's a
strategic thing where we have to find
some babysitters or we have to just
speak more encouragement into there that
it can do it because like you said not
every teacher is going to encourage them
right and do that what I noticed is just
taking something simple uh like Maslow's
hierarchy
a lot of the programs like Hey we're
gonna help you handle your money we're
gonna help you get a job we're going to
help you
um go to school
and on Maslow's hierarchy it you can't
do those higher order things
if I'm afraid of getting my head bashed
in at night or if my Granddad comes home
and lives with us and he's mapped out
all the time or if Mom has taken my
check and forging my social security
number and taken our my baby's formula
money too right so it's I tended to use
the um Maslow's hierarchy to say how
many of these needs can I solve on my
own and how many of these can I make
sure that there are a referral direct
referrals and not just well here's the
list of psychiatrists in the area but
where are some direct I'd go meet with
people but where are some direct
referrals and resources there on that
Maslow's hierarchy that would allow
people to then come in and go okay
my kids are safe I'm safe I got a warm
place to live I got a full belly
now I'm ready to learn I'm ready to
change my life and that's hard for folks
who are living a section I mean just two
are just grinding it and grinding it and
grinding it
um
I think it's gonna be a fun Retreat for
you and your staff to just reimagine the
whole thing and say how do we provide
pictures
so that the folks who walk in our doors
can say okay I'm here
oh I see her
be there
I see him I could be over there I could
where is a men's group for a group of
guys to get together in your community
just to say I'm not okay how are you
guys or a group of new moms or a group
of where can people get together and see
each other
and then you get a new picture and you
got a new picture then I can suddenly I
suddenly have a path forward when that
one kid in your neighborhood makes it
out
everybody goes okay I can do that if he
can do that I can do that
and I may not make it all the way to
where he made it but I can at least I
can at least uh I could at least go for
it thank you so so so much for your work
Lucy hope that helps um you're
infinitely more wise in this stuff than
I am because you're living it every day
but I hope those couple of those
suggestions weren't too lame and I hope
they help a little bit we'll be right
back
hey good folks John deloney here I I
feel like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramsesolutions.com that's
askjohn ramseysolutions.com with your
feedback thank you for being such an
important part of the show rock on
all right let's go to Panama City and
talk to Connor what's up Connor how we
doing
hey John thank you Jenna and the rest of
the team for taking my call today how
are you doing I'm doing outstanding and
uh I appreciate you being on the show
man so what's up how can I help yeah yes
I guess I want to start it off with a
little bit of background on this one so
Ken and I had a conversation last week
the question I'm going to ask you kind
of stem from the conversation he and I
had over employer issues that I'm having
now
um really is um flexibility on my work
schedule in a little bit and then uh
positional limitations for growth uh
promotion things like that that have
been happening over the last few months
ever since we've had some turnover
organization so bottom line I'm helping
raise a child that's not mine
genetically or adoptively but I do have
some in Loco parental stuff against it
so I do have some responsibility wise in
the legal scale for her why a little bit
of background on that situation yeah
this Max fiance's child and so her and I
are not together I'm kind of doing a
single parent Duty thing over here the
girls one and a half and she's adorable
lover to death but my employers have had
issues with me let me stop right there
let me stop right there why are you
involved at all in this
so her and I we split up a few years ago
when we didn't see eye to eye on our
values they didn't lie and we dated for
years and uh she went up to Georgia
after we split up and got pregnant the
guy after four months of pregnancy
stepped out got out of the picture she
came back down to Florida and I found
out about it through a mutual friend of
ours and I come from a family background
to where I was raised by single parents
my mother took off and I was very young
and I know what kind of impact I can
have on a child I mean I feel like God
put me in a place now to where I'm able
to support uh both mentally and
financially for the child on my side
here but being able to have you know a
dual parent household there is awesome
even if we aren't together it's still
good to have two parent figures in my
eyes
shh
uh I think you're setting everybody up
for an amount of heartbreak that is is
is going to be devastating on the
Richter scale
and here's why here's why you're playing
dad
you're performing dad
and you're not
this girl is always going to wonder why
her daddy left her
this little girl's always gonna be
grateful for this man who just
literally materialized and helped with
groceries and diapers
but also allowed mom to punt the
responsibilities
of raising a kid
you're playing you're playing dead and
you're pretending to be in a family with
a woman that y'all y'all made an adult
choice we're not right for each other
and we shook hands and we parted ways
she went and got pregnant happened love
it I don't don't have a an ill ill will
like an ounce of ill will in my heart
for her not I want the best for her
but then you came and swooped back in
and tried to
fast forward your lives three or four or
five years
see what I'm saying like it's it this
ends in a supernova at some point
either you meet somebody she meets
somebody and he cuts you out completely
oh I mean the whole thing's uh in local
Apprentice is a is a Doctrine it's not
law right it's it's in place of the
parent it's it's I don't know this this
whole thing feels like man it's about to
get real real messy
tell me I'm crazy be like hey you're an
idiot you don't actually know
I mean you're spot on with that and
that's really been my concern from since
the beginning of all this but I've been
in her license before she was born I
mean I drove in South Carolina when I
was at work there on part-time uniform
full-time Federal contractors so I was
up there in South Carolina for work for
a while came down for her birth I was
here so I mean I'm like she's I'm dad to
her and in my eyes she's my daughter but
we're having issues but but you're not
figure out the father situation in
Georgia and all that I know but you're
not
yeah
and you're not with her mom
yeah we try to make it work but of
course the values didn't know it's not
going to work yeah
and so the the
man you have one of the best hearts I've
ever met
thank you but it's it's being applied in
a way that is going to be so
it's just I just don't see a way this
place out
yeah and I've always been inking in the
back of my heart to something that's
really concerned me and really something
that's added an extra strain and stress
and I mean my employer is now adding to
that portion too by making my life
harder here in the office by not
accommodating me on certain things with
taking care of her when I get sick she
gets sick child care dropping off a
daycare in the morning so that they're
under the premise of well this is not
your child you have a responsibility so
I mean that's taking off work these
times and you don't have to
I see their point it's not your kid
um and the other side of it is if you
want to continue pretending she's your
kid you're gonna have to find a that's
on you to find a place that's going to
be flexible in that way
and it would be cool if they were just
like hey do you're growing up do
whatever you want to do
um I just don't I
or on the occasion you want to take you
know like I'm gonna take my neighbor's
kid in because my neighbor's kid sick
and my neighbors got to work but like
I'm just being a great neighbor right
that's that's something but all the time
man that's tough
yeah and it's one of those things where
it's not a huge like it's not affecting
my workplace performance any on this
side currently but it's just the whole
dynamic situation and they know about it
they know my past with the mother and
the kind of the situation they don't
agree with that on their side so they're
not really accommodating anything on
that hand which they have the right to
do and I know it's one of those things
where it's
I want what's best for the child at the
end of the day and it's one of those
things that's heavy in my heart because
I've waited so long the point where I'm
now attached and now other issues
starting to span from it but now it's
like a decision Factor has to be played
when she's a year and a half I mean she
won't know the difference right now
they're just think of me as some guy
who's may not even know me yours for now
authority to have that but I'll tell you
this
um I think I've talked about on the show
before I I think my son was two and a
half or three I have to go back and see
maybe four I don't know he's older than
a maybe four
um my wife uh was doing some Consulting
in right outside of Sao Paulo Brazil so
they paid for us to fly in so my son and
I just took like a 14 day trip maybe
it's 12 days we were just there forever
and it was just me and him hanging out
catching two I mean not catching but
like two cans were landing and we were
eating mangoes and avocados like off a
tree just in a yard and it was amazing
Road donkeys he remembers zero none zero
and I mean I thought Nick we made this
super trick none zero yeah he has no
memory at all and I tell you that like
um there will the the the
biological psychological emotional
spiritual consequence that machine is
already a motion
her dad left her gone disappeared
and I'll tell you this he might show
just show right back up
and he might not who knows
yeah but he she she's one and a half
your ex-fiancee
uh I mean
like let me just ask you a hard question
man like what are you like why are you
doing this
is it because were you jealous that that
somebody else got her pregnant like why
why what brought you back into this it
really wasn't that it's more from I
guess my past experience is really kind
of went round circle and I saw an
opportunity for me to be in a child's
life and make a huge difference on her
mentally physically spiritually
emotionally you know being there as dad
has always been something that I wanted
to do and wanted to have and I just I
thought this was a God thing to bring it
back in my life and maybe it was one of
those deceitful things that I thought
was a God thing but it was a mean thing
acting irrationally you know it it I
knew the dynamic was going to be hard I
just I didn't expect myself to go
through this amount of turmoil this
early on and it's not a mental turmoil
to stand somewhere I have an issue with
the child or issue with her mother it's
now like other things in my life let's
get it started to get impacted by it
when I mean in reality it shouldn't be
an issue but it's just they know it to
be not with an example they think would
be right for me to do and good for me
and they're looking out for me making my
life harder to try to almost force me
into making a decision
well I
I don't know that your employers got
that responsibility that that to me that
responsibility lays on my close friends
and people who I've given permission my
mentors who I've given permission to
hold me accountable for things yeah
they've been treating me like a child a
lot here and that's really one reason
elsewhere as well because they've been
limiting my growth potential on my age
well those guys I work with I've been an
organization seven years I'm 26 started
now I was 19. and all the guys I work
with they're I mean my boss about to
retire he's 62 like the average age is
46 50 more organizations it's an Air
Force command so we're in charge of Air
Force forces in the United States so
it's a pretty good response it's a
pretty big responsibility and a big job
but I've demonstrated myself performance
Wise It's just yeah I don't agree with
everything going on outside but
leadership is more than performance
leadership's also wisdom
yeah
leadership is wisdom
and there was nothing that made me more
enraged when I was 26 year old associate
dean of students that thought I knew
everything and people told me I wasn't
ready yet that phrase made me so enraged
until I became the chief student affairs
officer and I thought oh my gosh I was
not ready
you know the only perspective I had was
15 years later
right
I can't imagine how infuriating that is
to hear for me to say that so let me
just say like I get that right and
there's going to be a whole Spate of
YouTube 26 year olds who are like I'm
ready fine what I'm not gonna argue that
but I like
here's what I always want to keep in
mind
and this is right wrong or indifferent
but this is just how I choose to
navigate the world
um somewhat optimistically in an
obnoxious way
your bosses have a responsibility to
maximize profits they're a for-profit
company correct
uh we're the Air Force so not really yes
you're in the Air Force okay okay
bottle of Contracting here full-time I'm
part-time uniform here in National Guard
but I've been a contractor down here in
Florida for several years so his
contract is it a civilian contract
yeah a civilian contract okay their job
is to what make money right
yep yes
um they are going to put the people in
the position that's going to help them
best make the most money
now there's politics in every job
there's people who are idiots and have
stupid Egos and all that stuff I know
that exists but I tend to operate just
because it cleans my life up
if they don't promote me it's because
they thought I couldn't I wasn't the
person that would maximize the culture
here that would maximize profit here
that would maximize customer relations
here
and if it's nefarious or I think I'm the
right guy then I'm gonna go somewhere
else
and I've been doing that since October
I've been looking around applying it's
one of those frustration points where
I've been through a multiple job
opportunities multiple things but oh
yeah I have a very rich field it's hard
to translate on the outside and not get
very far in his interview process which
is frustrating ones like halfway to
three quarters of the way to even go
into our final interview on site yeah
and then I don't get it at that point so
it's been several jobs it's happened too
here's what I think you could really
benefit from
um
I think you need to call a licensed
mental health professional and not
because you have a mental health
disorder I don't hear that at all
but I think getting somebody that is a
neutral third party that you're
exchanging payment like I like like you
would a plumber
sitting down with somebody and saying
here are some choices I'm making here
are some frustrations and challenges I'm
running into
and let them hold up a mirror next to
you because they care about you and
they're professionals right you're
paying them
and say here's what I see
because here's what I see Connor I I see
somebody who is adjacent to the military
in it a little bit but adjacent to it
so you're in a limbo world
you're connected to it but through a
civilian route and that means you are
not you are kind of hierarchical but you
get you got stuck in this other lane
over here too
and man you loved this girl with all
your heart and then you all sat down and
made one of the hardest adult decisions
you're ever going to make which is I
love you and I probably always will love
you
but that doesn't mean we're right for
each other
and you'll split up
and then somebody else got your ex
fiance pregnant which would make any of
us just mad with all with every emotion
possible
you know what I mean
yeah and then you decided to try to
you're not even playing a house you're
playing divorce which is the strangest
game I've ever seen right yeah
you're playing divorce dynamic
um and you're you're it if I'm never
gonna tell if some man I'm never gonna
tell somebody he's like God's calling me
I'm never gonna fine like I I he didn't
call me he hadn't talked to me like that
but
um I'm not gonna tell you that he didn't
as an outsider it looks like you are
seeing a potential Good Deed
and you're so desperate to become the
hero in this story
that you are wallpapering over common
sense and your wallpapering over
responsibilities and accountability and
just trying to make it all right and
when I do that I run the risk of really
with my good intentions and my good
heart
causing a huge mess
if you care and love about this this
girl there's nothing to stop you from if
you want to starting your own your own
529 account for her to go to college
or creating some like there's all kinds
of ways to to participate without
pretending to be an ex the whole thing's
just confusing and a messy that's why I
think it's great for you to sit down
with an adult with a an adult with a
licensed professional and say I've dug
myself quite the hole
super frustrated at work to keep
overlooking me I'm 26 years old I don't
know why but clearly they're not doing
it because they think it's fun
they're leaning on me and pressuring me
and I feel it's very very personal maybe
it is maybe it's not I don't know
and Mana created a quagmire with the
beautiful one and a half year old little
girl who I love very much but that I
have absolutely no connection to a
relationship whatsoever other than I
used to date her mom
now I'm in a mess I need some help
and Connor
on Friday of last week I went and sat
with a counselor for two hours
the person who I think is one of the
best in
um
I I I'd put her up against most anybody
in the United States
and I said I'm in a mass I need some
help
it was an uncomfortable two hours but I
got a tiny little little flashlight I
hope on the back end of this thing
you're a good guy with a great heart
just need someone to help you clarify
some of the chaos and some of the mess
okay
there's a sunk cost fallacy it's common
in business when somebody starts a
business and they put five hundred
thousand dollars into it and the
business starts failing they immediately
want to say okay well I'm gonna put
another hundred thousand another hundred
thousand in it because I've already put
500 so what's 600.
and I've already put 600 so what's 800.
and it's really easy to do that
relationally too
I've already been with this girl for a
year and a half this little baby what's
another 16 and a half years
I've already I've already
the great
um
the great surgeons and the great you
know Physicians of our time know when to
say okay we don't know what's happening
but nobody's getting well let's stop
let's just stop and assess the damage
and then we'll make a new decision and
that's what I think you got to do you
gotta stop at the sunk cost foul so you
guys gotta pause
take a breath and look at this from 30
000 feet with somebody else by your side
I'll be here every step of the way my
brother as you sort this thing out
holler anytime but make that phone call
today and get yourself a professional
counselor you can talk to in your area
it's going to help you light the path
out of here we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
thank you
all right we are back uh
and that last call is gonna haunt me for
a minute
this is a very unpopular opinion out in
the
you go girl YOLO yeah bro world that we
live in
the uh your best truth which I just
think is nonsense
um
whatever you feel is true whatever you
want it like
there's something really important about
having a group of people around you that
or maybe one
two four that will call you and say hey
what are you doing stop stop
you think you're doing the right thing
and you're not
moral the story get some people in your
life that you trust and if you don't
have those people start with a license
counselor start with a therapist start
with a coach call somebody and then do
the gnarly hard work and get the
community together
none of us make good decisions when
we're emotional we don't we just don't
that's not how our brains are wired
we gotta have other people in our lives
man
it's a guy who's trying to do the best
he can and is just living out of some
childhood pain what a great guy and what
a mess
we'll be thinking about him all right as
we wrap up today's show uh some of my
favorite songs of all time
um the great John Mayer songs called
daughters and it goes like this
I know a girl she puts the color inside
of my world but she's just like a maze
where all of the walls all continually
change and I've done all I can to stand
on her steps with my heart in my hands
now I'm starting to see
maybe it's got nothing to do with me
fathers Be Good to Your Daughters
because daughters will love like you do
girls become lovers who turn into
mothers so mothers Be Good to Your
Daughters too
that's wise love you guys we'll see you
soon